the band we have a band called racket
which basically a it's a rock and roll
band and it was set up by myself and I
fella called nigel smith who's a scholar
of English literature in particular
Marvel and Milton he does some work on
him used to teach at Oxford I met him in
Oxford actually when I was a professor
of poetry at Oxford and he was the head
of the English department at Oxford he
like teaches at Princeton so he said you
know very very you know serious scholar
but behind it all he's a rocker and so
he and I got together and we started I
have always been interested in trying to
write songs I just would love to be able
to do it as there's quite a difficult
thing to do also but anyway we got
together and we set up the river band
they've been a couple of versions of it
but the present version of it it's a
great guitarist lead singer called lean
Matthew as a music scholar and then with
Steven Allen who's an entertainment
lawyer but a trained musician went to
the Berklee College of Music and then
our drummer Bobby Lewis is a also
studied music at the college of new
jersey trip and so they're all they're
all quite wonderful musicians but this
is bits rock and roll so rock and roll
with we hope you know Demi semi Tammy
semi-interesting lyrics we're hoping
we're hoping that's the idea so that
combination and you know we keep
plugging away at at it and you know we
do it for fun to a large extent but we
also work you know somewhat serious
about it also not in the sense that
we're expected to be playing Madison
Square Garden any day soon they'll find
you if there's anyone from Madison
Square Garden
listening you know you should think
about it and you know we have to be
realistic about that I suppose that
fixed by 56 year old like myself
shouldn't be cherishing even the
remotest notion of that but then I think
of Mick Jagger make Jagger's and
slightly better shape than I am as it
goes with any way and back to the
treadmill I write the lyrics that's my
main rule I write the lyrics i play the
odd some sometimes miscalculated chords
on a guitar but there you know I do so
with brio or certainly the attempt the
attempt of at brio I love it I mean it's
just it's so much fun and it's so much
fun and the band actually is great i
mean it's it's it's the dice or stand on
one side be praising myself but I said
they're quite brilliant there really are